Stephen it's lovely to see you here at
collector mania today I've been enjoying
it it's been great fun it's the first
one I've ever done and it's been a very
gentle baptism of what's not really been
a baptism of fire a baptism of what's
the opposite of fire nice warm fluffy
thing about ISM of nice warm fluffy
things yeah it's been really fun and
it's been really nice meeting some
Outlander fans as well I haven't met any
so far and I'm not on Twitter or
anything so it's been interesting to get
your reaction and what's the reaction
VIN so far very positive very positive
a slight disappointment from some of
them that either a I'm not Sam heughan
or bead some hyuna's in here but I
generally on the most part really nice
and they're a really really lovely bunch
of people I mean it's I'm it's it's
incredibly flattering that anyone wants
to come and get your st. photo you know
for anything so it's very nice now V
what's been the sort of favorite moment
of filming Outlander so far there was a
great it's a great scene in the episode
13 where Sam and I are salmon eyes
characters are mending a cart and we had
no idea what we were doing
whales meant to be mending this cart I
don't think either of us are
particularly practical so we kinda
mending the cart acting and were kind of
maiming hammering things about which
took is actually a few takes to manage
to get through the scene without
laughing but you know what - honestly so
much of it was just a really really
great fun everyone honor all the other
actors I got to work with were brilliant
tell me a little bit about getting into
your character Ian because obviously
this is a show that's based on books
yeah I got the book and and read that
which just like really helps to inform
the world that you're going into and you
know into there's a lot of the character
was in the script but also obviously
there's there's all you know from
anything as of the stuff missing from
the book so it's really good to get the
kind of insight into the character from
the book is John actually it did really
help in that sense getting the the idea
of the type of person I think the the
ENS and the war LT comes from and nevada
de zen and and i got the wooden leg for
a couple of weeks and prior to starting
to film and kind of at a practice
walking about on that home but it's very
very different walking at all more
wooden floorboards as opposed to walk on
cobblestones for the first time which is
very tricky
how many outtakes and bloopers are there
falling over or there's quite a few but
I actually know so many from me Catriona
valve was at Katrina valve Katherine
Katrina Bell was a there was a couple of
times I would walk into scenes and it
showed a cut because she'd already
started laughing because my hobbling n
apparently was so ridiculous and walking
up concrete steps for the first time was
pretty bloody hard so yeah there was
there was a few and it was one in
particular actually where the wooden leg
came flying off and to a ball of
cabbages which was pretty pretty
spectacular
so these being the DVD we've deleted
scenes apparently they were on they were
on the blooper reel at the wrap party
but I can go to the wrap party cuz I was
I was in Prague filming something else
so I missed it but I'm yeah if there's a
thousand oh it takes real on the DVDs
I'm sure one of them will be on there I
look forward to oh that's the case and
what can we look forward to going ahead
for Outlander now well I guess you know
I haven't read the second book so I
don't know exactly I don't know exactly
what happens but the fans will know
probably more than me in that sense I
you know from what I gather there Sam
and Jamie and cleared off in France at
the beginning on there no and can't even
listing the help of Bonnie Prince
Charlie and come back to Scotland so
hopefully more you know more of what
made the first season so great and you
know by the sounds of it more great
characters new people and a you know
hopefully Moravian Marie I think you
know much more of you Marie I would make
the whole thing much much better so
definitely start the petition here yeah
absolutely
come on if you could have anything
happen to your character going forward
what would you like to see and get up -
um I wouldn't mind I'm seeing maybe
getting his right leg back click
actually growing a proper leg although
having said that I do quite enjoy
walking with the wooden leg
it's after about you it was actually
pretty good fun I'd like to see and
maybe I was going to say late to see Ian
getting into some fighting action but
then having said that he's kind of moved
you know as I was explained in season
one is going to move past that now and
he's killing days are over so I don't
know maybe just fathering more babies no
matter which he does do a lot of
actually anyway I think according to the
book so even called back in for season
two
ah yes I have I don't know again exactly
where I'm going to be back corner but
towards the end of the the year and
suppose it depends how accurately the
spear to stick with the books or not
tell me a little bit about working with
your co-stars on the show Oh as I said
working with Sam it was really great fun
uh what's with some and what was I'm
sorry Sam was out my drama school he was
two years below me and and so I didn't
know him really well but I knew him you
know well enough to be acquainted with
but it was I think we share quite a
similar sense of humor and the chemistry
that I think came across and the show
hopefully
was like very genuine right so it was
really really
the label wrote we were having a real
laugh
off-camera as well which really helps
and cats fantastic as well really funny
really great really enjoyed all the all
the stuff with her and
and Laura I knew a little bit from
before as well Laura was at my drama
school I think she went after I left but
I kind of like met her over the years
here in there and Laura was brilliant as
well and she saw she's so great at
playing Jenny as well it made it very
very easy to react off of them react off
of what she gave and I absolutely love
the dogs as well pan and Marilyn I don't
know how feature pan and Marilyn are on
it but yeah I want more of the dogs it's
not no it's her favorites but especially
pan the little dog I loved pan yeah how
is it then working with animals who say
never work with animals and children
don't though I saw this yeah they were
fain and I've worked with rats just
recently not on Outlander on something
else and I never would have thought I
would want to work with rats and it was
actually actually was a strange to quite
pleasant experience almost very
surprisingly pleasant and Marilyn and
pan and Outlander were great
you know they borrowed didn't really
they weren't stretched too much they
kind of sat quietly but the sat quietly
very very well I've never worked with I
don't think I've ever worked with
children really I mean it's obviously we
Jamie and Islander but again he wasn't
you know I didn't we didn't really much
to do with them but I think they said
out just because they're better than you
you know animals and children generally
are better than you in the scene because
they're just getting on with it and not
thinking so what else can we look
forward to coming up from you I will
also be in half the rare cards which is
a new comer they starting on Dave I kind
of same improvised thing with David
Hasselhoff
yeah which which I think will be I think
it'll be pretty funny it's certainly
pretty outrageous
so was it like working with him I saw
HOF amazing absolutely bro he's a really
nice guy and very he was really really
up for having a laugh and totally up for
having the pest tech you know of them
which was essential for the show to work
I think and he's very good as well and I
barely on it and yeah I mean I was kind
of surreal at first but actually you
very quickly when you're doing stuff you
very quick cycle I often have worked
with actors in the past I really really
admire do you work with something who's
a hero you a kid and it's a bit surreal
it faster then you just get over it and
not just who they are and it's the same
with their with with the half but yeah
certainly the first you know I I
remember when I was 14 years old and
watching Baywatch for the first time and
probably most 14 year old boys been
absolutely blown away by the by the
credits at the start so it was pretty
cool with that in mind did you tell him
that and also um yeah they tell not yeah
I say Hasselhoff I think you were
responsible for a lot of erections all
over the world simply by the credits of
Baywatch alone his response was always
like yeah cool yeah yeah I don't think
he could understand a lot of why I said
he would laugh and play yeah yeah yeah
cool but you know huevos
I think Sammy wondering what the hell I
was talking about so what kind of
improvised it as the Hoff mate he went
with whatever he was whatever
he was given or whatever he gave back
you know so he wasn't like nothing
flummoxed um or shark Tom and I was
trying very hard to come up with the
most ridiculous and outlandish things
that I could and and he's obviously you
know he's obviously lived a life and
isn't very easily shocked so he went
with everything that he was given and
gave back as well so he was yeah he was
great
it's lovely talking to you Stephen thank
you very much
you